what's your favorite animal um
oh my gosh she's so cute
we brought together 17 moms i am a teen
mom i am
a teen mom i am a teen mom i'm a teen
mom i'm a teen mom i'm a teen mom
no i'm a teen mom one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll win a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the cash
prize this
is old man out
[Music]
having a baby like your life just
changes like that i think what's gonna
set the mole and a real teen mom apart
is the details have you lost or have you
gained friends
are you still with your baby's father i
definitely wouldn't have known what the
hell
goes on during the postpartum stage or
like after birth stuff like that
if i do too much people might be
suspicious of me and think that i'm like
overdoing it
i feel confident but i'm nervous the
mole will probably be like a nanny
maybe like a big sister
[Music]
hi hi hi how old are everyone
wait the babies are us both i turned 18
in august and my baby's
10 months but he turns 11 months
tomorrow almost a year oh my goodness
that's so exciting
i am 15 and my baby is 4 months
i'm 19 and my daughter just turned 21
months today
i'm 17 and i've got an eight month old i
am 19
and i have a two-year-old daughter i
just turned 18.
my daughter's two and a half she just
turned two in april
i'm 14 and i have an eight month old and
she turns one in march
so how about you guys birth story how
long were you guys in labor i was in
labor for 47 hours
it was miserable but of course it was
worth it i was in labor for 11 hours
i'm jealous labor is no joke did you
guys have epidurals did you guys go
natural
i had epidural i can't do natural did
anybody get induced
like half and half like they broke my
waters i didn't even want an epidural
but at like 38 hours i was like i'm
either gonna yeah i was like i'm gonna
have to have a c-section like i have no
strength left in my body i only got to
six centimeters that's why i had to have
a c-section
your body wouldn't progress um the
umbilical cord was wrapped around her
neck
same my baby came out all blue and
purple it was
he didn't even cry when he came out i
was literally soaked he was my hair my
baby didn't either
when i didn't hear him cry i was just
like please tell me my baby's okay
i bet your heart just dropped yes they
don't cry for a while though like you
think they'll cry
yeah but i've heard like the movies they
just probably like a minute
we just all seemed like we were just
team moms just chatting having a good
time
i like hearing like everyone's stories
because i know not everyone's labor is
the exact same so it's like nice to hear
i feel like emma is actually a mom and i
feel like so shana
the other three they were quite quiet so
far i'm the most suspicious of kira
this is a total random guess i'm so
sorry girl but i'm have to vote for you
emma really stuck out to me she is who i
will be voting on
i am definitely most suspicious of kiana
i think i'm saying her name right i
think i'm gonna vote for kimberly
i don't know i'm gonna vote off kimberly
i'm kind of suspicious of kayla
i think this round i'm gonna vote out
kayla i'm so sorry girl
she was just not giving me mom vibes the
votes are in and we have a tie between
kimberly and
kayla so we're going into a tiebreaker
each one of you will get 20 seconds to
state your case
first up is kayla so i realized that i
was pregnant when i was 16
gave birth 17 now i'm 18 years old i'm
balancing school
while raising my 10 with baby my mom was
a teen mom so like
it was just like really hard having to
come out with that because
i feel like it made it seem like i was
like following her footsteps so she was
like really disappointed about that so
that was like really hard for me
i found out i was pregnant july 19 with
my boyfriend he bought me the pregnancy
test
i told my mom well she found out because
she noticed because i was really open
about my period to her she made me take
a pregnancy test
in front of her and my dad um was
outside the restroom
we told the school they had found
resources and i moved into
a school for pregnant teens and teen
moms
the votes for the tiebreaker are in and
the teen mom eliminated in round one
is kayla
bye sorry girl i genuinely thought she
was a teen mom
i had to vote for kayla just because
kimberly had a strong story i wish i
would have stayed longer i really wanted
to show my baby
[Music]
she is a pretty good baby she only cries
when she's trying to go to sleep and you
will not stand up
say hi right now she's learning how to
use her hands and stuff because she's so
young i don't really have like her
favorite things
but she does love cocoa melon like if
she sleep and i put cocoa melon on
she'll wake up and watch it she loves
animals this
girl this girl is not afraid of anything
we have a bearded dragon her name is
saffron
the second she walks in nobody doesn't
have a smile on their face
he's currently teething so he's having a
lot of sleepless nights
which is why he's actually up this late
because i'm in the uk he is usually all
around a happy little boy giggling
smiling always talking and
interacting her favorite thing is coco
melon
and she loves to watch blippi she loves
to do little dance parties
what's your favorite color what's your
favorite animal
um elmo uh her very animal
elmo apparently her dad is not involved
but she's still
thriving she likes eating a lot
everything i eat she eats too
she crawls a lot now she's very
talkative
and very friendly like she won't cry
with anyone
she's hungry right now her favorite
things are
unicorns dressing up being a princess
you love princesses huh
okay it was kind of a fight to get her
out of a princess dress today but
we managed to do it right
oh yeah whenever you meet her she just
like won't say much and
she's pretty reserved perfect do you
understand i i had one movie
i thought it was really cool seeing all
the babies they all looked exactly like
their moms i feel like people might
suspect me because
i have a toddler and the rest of them
had like babies who were like super
attached to them
i don't know if we've got them all out i
don't think kayla was the mole i still
have a really weird suspicion
about kimberly i'm just gonna go with
kimberly
no valid explanation i am going to go
with emma this time like i did before
just because
in this situation against the other
girls the other girls are kind of
a little bit calmer than her if i had to
vote for someone though
i think i would vote for kiana i want to
say i'm kind of suspicious of kiana
so i figured out how to say kiana's name
and i say i'm still most suspicious
about her
i'm scared
i knew it i thought it was gonna be me
okay
i didn't really have too much to say
about my child because she is so young
all the other moms had a lot to say but
we will see
[Music]
i thought i was pregnant for like a
couple weeks but i was kind of in denial
and so my boyfriend my now fiance but he
was my boyfriend at the time oh
congratulations
thank you and so we had stopped at 7 11
to grab some candy and some snacks to
sneak into the movie theater
i just got like the cheapest pregnancy
test and then i took it in the movie
theater bathroom when i came out
he just could read my face and he said
you're pregnant aren't you
and i said yep and he goes well we'll
figure it out you've never broken up
he's always been the best dad that's so
good
and i hid my pregnancy my parents found
out
yeah surprise literally everybody was
like oh my god
yeah but i didn't show like at all and i
just wear a sweatshirt
okay yeah and i worked two jobs the
whole time i was pregnant so we could
support her in
yeah that's my story my mom i actually
got grounded and i was in trouble
and she took away my phone i decided to
text my friend on messenger on my
computer
and i was telling her that i had like a
bunch of symptoms because she's also a
teen mom
and she said yeah you're pregnant and my
mom had seen the text coming through my
phone
so she read them and just
let loose on me and then once my dad
found out he was
the most supportive my dad is like very
religious so he's like things happen for
a reason
we stand supportive parents one thing
that happened when i was in high school
i got a lot of judgment so i had to move
to online school and some people
actually tp
my house while i was pregnant that's
horrible
and wrote god a [ __ ] and a hoe
that's terrible i'm so sorry you had to
go through that oh my gosh
yes in june i was getting period cramps
but my period wasn't coming so i googled
that up and the first thing that came up
was pregnancy
i had told my boyfriend and he came over
to my house but this was in
july and he brought the pregnancy test
and i took it
and he was happy but um i kind of had a
blank expression on my face i didn't
really know
what to think i didn't want to believe
it i'm so emotional
oh oh bless me girl just cry i'm gonna
cry
i cry when other people cry and my
parents found out in
august because they noticed that i
wasn't getting my period i had told a
couple friends and they
told me to a boy but i knew i wasn't
gonna do that
me and my boyfriend have been together
for almost three years in february
everyone loves um my baby now and
oh girl yeah that's it like i'm i'm
really happy
with how my life is right now yeah i
love that
okay so i was 15 when i found out i was
pregnant the first person i told was
obviously my boyfriend whose name is
zach we didn't plan it but he was like
no you've got to keep it we're amazing
together we're going to start a life
together both my parents were really
really supportive
they explored so many routes of what i
could have gone through and it was
amazing to have that support especially
from parents
but then about five months down the
pregnancy line me and my boyfriend
actually broke up
we completely blocked each other we
didn't talk to each other never saw each
other
on his due date he actually got back in
contact with me and then we got back
together and then our son was born
four days later and we're still together
now
so i found out i was pregnant at 15.
my school is like a high school that
also has an infant lab in the school
which is like a daycare type thing
so they have a teen clinic where they
like do like pregnancy tests like std
checks like literally everything one day
i went there after school with one of my
good friends
and i found out i was pregnant there the
doctor just kind of walked into the room
and she just like stood there so i'm
like oh boy
like here we go yeah i kind of knew like
from her like expression that
i was pregnant and me and my boyfriend
were only together for
it was like a month at the time and he
was 14 and i was 15. he was just mainly
really scared to tell his parents yeah
my parents were super supportive though
my mom was a teen mom herself
thankfully the school i go to has an
infant lab a daycare thing i'm able to
bring her to school with me still
and this year is my last year congrats
can't wait to graduate oh my goodness
i'm gonna be the first in my family
it's gonna be something that's amazing
either the mole is a really
good actor or we already got it i'm not
suspicious of anyone
i don't know unfortunately i'm going to
vote
shanna out this round i really hate to
because she seems
really nice if we didn't vote out the
mole i'm gonna be mad
i'm suspicious of kyra and i'm going to
be voting for her
i'm still very very suspicious of
kimberly in the 20 seconds about me like
her tie-breaker i swear she said her
parents found out and they bought her
pregnancy test because i have to vote
for one i'm gonna say kimberly
just for the fact that she had the least
detail she was the least descriptive i
think i'm gonna vote for kimberly
no i'm so sorry i i had no idea who to
vote for
i feel bad i'm sorry i feel like they
voted me out because i was
crying i don't know i guess i'm watching
it whenever i tell my story
give me a thumbs up if you want to
continue the game if not
give me a thumbs down and you think you
caught them all and want to end the game
right now
this is so nerve-wracking yeah i know if
the color that shows up is green
you all win if it's red the fake teen
mom is still in the game and you all
lost
in three two one
we did it almost not so anxious
who was it
the game is over and the teen moms have
won we're also going to be gifting them
the akintu
experience where they'll get to pick
their favorite basics from our new
interactive apparel brand
i would like them all to please reveal
yourself in three
two one
i knew it i knew it oh my goodness
oh you did good good job
that is one cute baby though oh my
goodness whose baby is it
it's my mom's baby he's my little
brother i believe someone was gonna do
that
i knew it when you go out to people
think it's yours
um sometimes yeah yeah i've forgotten
that i babysit him a lot
bye baby